help me
right here
a touching reunion
[Music]
well guys your girl finally made it to
midgar
my name is yuffie materia hunter and
elite special forces operative for the
new wutai government
will prove to our common enemy that
wutai is not to be trifled with
members of avalanche we got this i'm
back
ah there you are someone's been
expecting you what took you
sorry about that anyway it's nice to
meet you
i'm sonan kasakabe where's clown we lost
him
you what he will be okay though right
well of course he will they're the ones
who blew up the reactors
cool should we say hi no
better not after what they've done
you've got to assume shinra's on their
tail
look a moogle stop
we gotta help
[Music]
no freaking way
you guys should probably get moving got
it whatever it is they're planning
you're better off out of it they deserve
what's coming
yeah they do but i'm not your sister
there you are who are these jerks no
clue we just appeared
[Music]
now let the hunch begin
get down here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wait what
you see that that's how ninjas do it
[Music]
yep
you